il y a un peu plus de 7 mois dans une
attaque illégale
brutale meurtrière
la Russie a tenté d'envahir l'Ukraine
[Musique]
c'est un membre de la famille européenne
qui est agressée ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont attaquées
notre détermination face aux nouvelles
impérialisme russe qui est éprouvé
[Musique]
ce conflit dure et durera ses
conséquences sont concrètes et
perceptibles dans toute l'Europe et dans
notre pays depuis ce matin les cours
sont suspendus sur ce campus de la
capitale iranienne des manifestations
qui s'amplifient aussi dans toutes les
grandes villes du pays hier encore à
Esparron ces jeunes ont forcé le portail
de la faculté
on va retenir que les 8 mais non ça
c'est
un peu tout le monde
sont l'oeuvre de l'Amérique et du régime
sioniste d'Israël avec l'aide de
certains iraniens traîtres à l'étranger
on absent Adrien s'il ne sera pas à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi et sa femme a
porté plainte le 26 septembre dernier
contre lui à Lille elle avait déjà
déposé demain courante pour les mêmes
scènes Sandrine Rousseau ressuscite les
process staliniens sont partis Europe
écologie des vers utilisent les méthodes
de feu la Stasi pour espionner des
camarades comme on écoutait les
conversations privées dans le la vie des
autres cette plante a été déposée contre
lui après de nombreux messages qu'Adrien
catenin saurait envoyer sur son
téléphone
l'expérience totalité n'a eu aucun
véritable retentissement c'est comme si
le 20e siècle n'avait pas eu lieu et le
néo féminisme est aujourd'hui une sorte
de
totalitarie je suis
je suis en colère de voir leur madame
borne nous faire des leçons alors
qu'elle a Monsieur Darmanin qui a avoué
avoir demandé des faveurs sexuels à une
femme pour en échange d'un logement il y
a pas d'enquête en cours sur Gérald
Darmanin
Rousseau et d'autres aller manger vos
morts
tout simplement et encore moins quand on
est député de la République par rapport
à des femmes qui se battent et qui
disent à des politiques attention là
vous êtes des collabos expliquez-moi ça
veut dire quoi manger vos morts
je pense que vous savez utiliser un
moteur de recherche et vous saurez avoir
l'explication et c'est un tweet fort de
boutade de salutations du matin qui a
pas besoin de plus de commentaires je
sais que vous adorez faire ça le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée Alexis
colère et mise en examen pour prise
illégale d'intérêt Alexis colère a par
ailleurs été placé sur le statut de
témoin assisté pour trafic d'influence
vous pouvez trouver choisissez ça déjà
été fait à mon encontre tous les tweets
possibles et imaginables pour les
décortiquer je pense que c'est en tout
en dessous y compris de ce que vous êtes
censé faire et éclairer le débat public
avec un contenu politique qui va être
intéressant
le secrétaire général de l'Elysée a
approuvé en 2010 et 2011 des contrats
concernant l'armateur MSC fondé et
dirigé par des cousins de sa mère ce que
je vous propose aujourd'hui c'est de
pouvoir changer les choses ensemble j'ai
besoin que vous puissiez aussi prendre
part au travail du Conseil national de
la refondation
et donc avec vous qui portez des idées
de changement qui imaginaient des
projets pour nos territoires qui avaient
des idées très concrètes de pouvoir nous
en faire part en les mettant en commun
sur conseils
Éric Dupond-Moretti renvoyé en process
c'est une première pour un garde des
sceaux en exercice il est accusé d'avoir
profité de sa fonction pour régler ses
comptes avec des magistrats à qu'il a eu
à faire lorsqu'il était avocat ses
avocats ont formé un pourvoi en
cassation